hey guys it's max with max tech welcome
to my two-week honest review on the
iPhone 10 are where I'm gonna give you
guys my real-world experience
switching over to the iPhone 10 are from
the 10s max and before that I use the
iPhone 10 I'm gonna answer all the
questions that I had when I first got my
hands on this device and yes I will
explain why I'm returning it so let's
start out with the most talked-about
aspect of this phone and let's get it
straight out of the way from the get-go
and that is this LCD display that is
lower than 1080p resolution now yes I
was kind of hating on this along with
everybody else when Apple announced it
that in almost 2019 we're getting a
phone that can't even do 1080p and
people are gonna buy the Sony and use it
for multiple years and after these two
weeks I want to say it is not that big
of a deal there are some downsides there
are some things that bug me and I'll
talk about that in just a bit but the
actual resolution the pixel density
doesn't matter that much I can tell that
the text is not as crisp now yes my eyes
are used to a nice Ola displaced in
Stifel Anton came out for my computer
I'm using an LG ultra fine 5k monitor so
I am kind of trained to see a really
detailed text but yes it is noticeable
now one thing that's even more
noticeable that's more kind of annoying
to me is if you're looking at a white
screen you could tell that the edges are
darker than the center that's because it
has have backlighting here and Apple
really did a fantastic job in
engineering to be able to pull off
mostly full screen display with all
these curved edges other companies
aren't even pulling this off with OLED
and it's really difficult they had some
really really good engineer to be able
to pull this off what bugs me more is if
you're watching a video in portrait mode
like this and I often do that I read
through my youtube comments I read
through other people's YouTube comments
I kind of engage with people this is
where you notice limitations of the
lower pixel density screen and when you
have kind of straight lines that are
going diagonal you notice aliasing on
those those lines and that's something I
ever haven't really noticed even with my
iPhone 6 + 7 + 8 + going to my iPhone 10
10 s max but with this phone I do see it
and that does kind of bug me now the
thing that I really don't like is not
having forced touch and that's been a
huge effect for me personally now to be
honest I really didn't
think that a use force touch very much I
all said it's kind of like a gimmick
something that they add in to be an
extra feature but it's not really very
useful I started using a little bit more
once we had this upgraded lock screen
and I'd use it for the flashlight maybe
deleting some notification stuff like
that but I really didn't think it was
such a big part of my user experience
until a couple days into using the
iPhone 10 our during the presentation
Apple said that they replace it with
something called haptic touch so you can
just hold down on something for a little
bit and I'll go ahead and turn on but in
the real world a lot of the previous
things that you can interact with and
you can force touch are completely gone
so some of the apps that you can press
down things like having a note of
notification pop up and you can force
touch and kind of remove it or interact
with it delete something being able to
just delete emails from your lockscreen
something that I used to do all the time
is just completely gone so as far as the
resolution it's really not that big of a
deal I think most people won't have an
issue but if you're somebody that uses
force touch often I would definitely
consider if it's worth getting this
device or trying to spend more on an
iPhone 10s
now one positive due to the low
resolution of the display is the battery
life it's a lot more efficient and one
question was is this can have the best
battery life in any iPhone based on
Apple's ratings it should but no I don't
think so it is super super good but the
iPhone 10's max I think personally was
better at the end of the day I would
have a little bit more battery life than
this phone and I do use my phone a lot I
put it through a lot of use throughout
the day it is a workhorse definitely
better than iPhone 10 and the iPhone 8
plus and my iPhone 8 and those kind of
phones but if you're trying to buy this
phone to get an advantage over the
iPhone 10's max that is not going to be
the case now let's jump into my favorite
thing about this phone and that is the
display size 6.1 inches and I found it
to be perfect for my large hands when I
switched from the iPhone 8 plus to the
iPhone 10 because it was a flagship
device I really found it to be small
even though the screen technically is
larger in the real world if you're
looking at the surface area it was
smaller this thing is just right the
iPhone 10's max which is what I'm
switching back to just feels a bit large
even though I have large hands it's kind
of clumsy to use it's cumbersome it's
definitely a two-handed device the
iPhone titles of it
small for me and this thing is just
perfect I love love love the size and if
they offer in an iPhone 10s version in
the size I would definitely be going for
it now another thing I really like are
the color options so this one is yellow
I bought it for my wife which she's not
going to be getting it anymore but I
really like the red color I really like
the blue color so I think that's so cool
the Apple decided to add a little bit of
fun back into these phones
unfortunately the yellow and the sides
here because it is a different material
it doesn't match so it kind of looks
really similar to the previous gold that
you get with the anodized aluminum
phones but overall that part of it is
really nice I want to comment on the
actual design of it it feels good it
feels nice in the hand but it just does
not compare to the iPhone 10s or the
iPhone 10 when you have the stainless
steel and you have the coloring on here
it just feels so much more premium now
along with that we do have the same CPU
we have the same kind of graphics but we
also do have a difference in RAM three
gigs of ram versus four gigs of ram have
I noticed a difference in RAM that was
one of the questions that I wanted to
answer for myself no I have not had any
issues with RAM management apps are
loading up just fine everything is super
smooth super quick animations are great
no lag whatsoever so I don't really
think that Ram difference really matters
now the biggest difference about the LCD
specifically to me personally is the
off-axis shift so if you're not looking
directly at the device if you're looking
off to the side you get a noticeable
reduction in brightness and contrast now
I often turn on a YouTube video I set my
phone next to me on my desk and I'm
writing a script I'm doing some video
editing I'm doing some researching and
I'm playing a video off to the side and
they'll kind of glance down at it and
keep doing my work and the first day you
started using device I set it up exactly
like this I look over and I look huh
that video is really dark what's going
on
did they under expose it or where's my
brightness whoo I pick it up oh and that
looks looks good I turned my brightness
all the way up which is basically all
the way up I set it back down and then a
couple minutes later I kind of glanced
over why is it so dark again and with
the iPhone 10 and the 10s max that's not
a problem the off-axis shift is
basically minimal it works fantastic but
with iPhone 10 art that is an issue so
think about it if you use your phone in
that way now finally let's get
the biggest reason why I'm returning the
iPhone 10 are and spending the extra
cash and getting my wife an iPhone 10s
and that is this guy right here the
camera now surprise when Apple announces
they're putting a saint
8:12 processor in this phone as the
iPhone 10s something that's super
powerful already beating the more than
powerful enough a 11 Bionic chip and I
was even more surprised when they said
that they're putting the same new sensor
the same lens the same smart HDR
technology in this phone as the iPhone
10s and I was shocked when they showed
off portrait mode working on this phone
with a single lens now this has been a
big reason why I bought the plus size
models and why my wife got the plus size
models to have that portrait mode and
have the extra telephoto camera to be
able to do that now unfortunately when
this phone started shipping reports
started coming out that this phone
cannot take Porsche mode photos of
objects only people so that is a big
limitation if you want to take pictures
of your pets if you want to take
pictures of products if you do gear
reviews if you just want to take nice
cool portrait mode photos with some nice
blur you cannot do that unless it's a
person so I think that is a big
limitation personally I use the Porsche
mode really often to put something up on
Instagram just to take some more
pleasing photos that look more like a
DSLR it's so convenient so fast and it
really it does quite a good job and you
cannot do that with iPhone 10r and this
is a bummer I really hope that they add
this in the future now I see what
they're doing to get people to spend
more money on this phone and if we look
at some of the Android competition some
of those phones with single lens cameras
are still able to take a picture of a
static subject and do a great job so I
really hope Apple adds to sin now
comparing these two this thing will be
able to give much more blur if you
adjust it on the slider for portrait
mode because it has a longer telephoto
lens with more compression and it looks
naturally get a ton of blur which this
one they made it kind of more true to
life where you wouldn't have that much
blur if you're using a wider shot now an
even bigger downside I think personally
is the fact that this phone will only
zoom in three times if you're taking
photos or videos compared to 10 times
zoom with the iPhone 10s so with all of
that said I want to say that the iPhone
10 R is a good phone it just doesn't
feel like a great phone price-wise it's
right
Queen where we had died phone 8/9 1/8
plus and on top of that you get this
nice display that fills up most of the
frame it really feels like a new design
which it is borrowing from the iPhone 10
has stepped forward into the future we
have faced ID which is fantastic we have
a super-fast processor that is way
faster than we need we have a good
amount of RAM we have a nice design nice
colors a nice camera even though it's
limiting compared to some of the
competition and the 10s and 10's max
models so it is a good phone a lot of
people are gonna buy this phone a lot of
people can be happy if you're upgrading
say from the iPhone 7 or 8 you're gonna
be super happy and even if you're
upgrading from the 7 plus or the 8 plus
I think you're also going to be happy as
long as you're not somebody that's
really reliant on forced touch or taking
portrait mode shots of objects this is a
great all-around phone for you and a
great all-around phone for the masses
Apple is doing a good job they're gonna
sell a ton of these but chances are if
you're watching this video you might be
either into tech maybe you use your
phone a ton and you need to know which
one to use maybe you're just looking for
justification somebody to push you over
the edge and give you an excuse to spend
more money on the iPhone 10s or 10s max
that's exactly what I'm gonna do I'm
returning the iPhone 10 R because I
think it is worth spending the extra
money as long as you can afford it on
the iPhone 10s if you look at the bigger
perspective over to three or even four
years you break that money down as long
as you can afford it I think it really
makes sense you're gonna get thinner
bezels a beautiful gorgeous OLED display
with pure blacks it's gonna get brighter
it's not gonna have off axis shift
issues much sharp or just a big step up
from the LCD display no kind of back
lighting issues or anything like that
you're gonna get better waterproofing
you're gonna get the second camera here
so you can zoom in 10 times instead of
three times be able to take portrait
shots of static objects have better edge
kind of detection I think that is really
really nice to have you're gonna get a
forced touch with this you're gonna get
that gigabit LTE and even if you can't
make use of that now like I can't maybe
some of you guys can but six months down
the line a year down line two years down
line you're going to get better
reception and faster speeds with that
so I think if you're gonna
or this especially if you don't use a
case it just feels so nice
spend the money I think it is well worth
it so thank you guys for watching my
two-week review on the iPhone 10 are
hopefully you enjoyed it if you did
please hit the like button if you guys
have any questions ask in the comments
section below you can also let me know
your opinion which one did you go for
and why and what is your experience I
think it's a fantastic phone like I said
Apple's gonna sell a lot of them but for
the tech community and the people that
really spend a lot of their times on
their phones to take a lot of pictures
the iPhone 10s and 10's max
is a better option this has been max
with max tech and I'll see you in the
next video